libs are so upset about this they're so
upset because conservatives finally
are really
getting aggressive on these social
issues and they're giving the people
what they want and according to the libs
this is a great threat to democracy i'm
a black gay woman and i have a daughter
so i'm not doing so well right now
i'm a little salty
you're a little salty i'm a little salty
right now okay yeah yeah we'll sprinkle
a little salt yeah
let's put some flavor on it sucks man it
it really does i mean you know it's like
the the country it's no longer a
democracy right i mean we're it's no
longer majority rule
no certainly not the senate certainly
yeah the representation of the supreme
court it's not it's not it's no longer
majority rule i love hear stephen
colbert who is somewhat intelligent he
realizes that what wanda sykes is saying
doesn't make any sense and so he's
trying to
make it seem like it makes sense it's no
longer a democracy which why because of
the dobbs decision because of a decision
where the judiciary is giving away power
and is say no we're not going to make a
decision about this issue we're going to
give it back to the people and their
representatives we're going to expand
democracy and she says it's no longer a
democracy colbert is just thinking how
do i
how do i make this extremely dumb
statement sound like it might sort of he
goes yes well certainly not yeah not
when it comes to
the judiciary and the supreme court or
the the senate and the supreme court
the the
judiciary
the supreme court were never
democratic exactly they're democratic in
the sense that people vote for electors
and the electors elect the president the
president appoints
the judges and the judges are confirmed
by the senate and the senate previously
was sent by the states and the people
like the state representatives now that
people directly elect the senators so
there's some democratic tie-in but the
supreme court is not supposed to be the
most democratic institution they have a
life tenure for a reason it's to balance
out the tyranny of the majority
and then the senate is
fairly democratic it's not a one-to-one
uh representation of the people in the
country but it does give representation
to the the various states and they're
elected by the people of those states so
he's trying to thread this needle she's
seeing this really dumb
dumb point but then she gets to
a really key political lesson
the problem is that middle stuff it's
those states in the middle that that red
stuff
why they get to tell us
what to do when the majority of us live
out you know new york california and
we're paying for all this crap really i
mean right
we're footing the
so that's that's the union it's supposed
to be a representative democracy but it
turns out to be minority rule right now
right right but if we fit in the bill
you know and and and like california if
it were a country be what like the fifth
largest
fourth fifth largest economy so if you
know if i'm fitting the bill know your
position you know what i'm saying
you know for real like look if i say hey
let's go out to dinner you don't get to
pick the restaurant just shut up and eat
there it is shut up and eat so she's
saying the majority of americans live in
new york and california that's not true
that's not even close to true it might
be true in her mind but then she points
out she's saying okay i'm not really
talking about the majority of americans
i'm just talking about the majority of
where the money comes from
i'm not you're right i'm not talking
about democracy because we're talking
about democracy then the people get what
they want and and the people don't
support my radical views but i'm talking
about well i guess i'm talking about
oligarchy i guess i'm talking about
money because yeah you in this country
while maybe the liberal states are
are not the majority uh we we make all
the money baby all the rich people are
democrats and so if you're not making
all the money and you're not paying for
everything then shut your mouth and do
what we say and let us trans your kids
and let us kill your babies and let us
do whatever the hell we want you know
like democracy right when they say
democracy i've said this for a long time
not the first one to say it but
i have been saying it for a long time
when they say democracy they mean
liberalism they mean leftism they mean
progressivism when they when they weep
philosophic about our democracy our
sacred democracy what they're referring
to is their oligarchy and you heard it
from wanda sykes and you see stephen
colbert nodding along
they are going to tell us what to do we
have one political advantage here the
political advantage we have is that the
people broadly don't like that stuff and
the people broadly are on our side and
it's time to exercise that political
power they've got a lot of institutional
power we do still have that basic fact
of political power right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast
the american people are getting pinched
right now you are getting pinched right
now gas is going way way up everything
that you're buying at the store is going
way way up if you're like me and you're
probably looking at your budget right
now
one way that you can really save a lot
of money is on your cell phone plan
because your cell phone companies those
big cell phone companies are charging
you a bazillion dollars what are you
paying you're probably paying 70 80 90 a
month per line
for what for the exact same service that
you could get from pure talk for 30 a
month
all the talk you want all the text you
want all the data that you want for 30 a
month on america's best 5g network why
on earth would you pay those gigantic
awful cell phone companies when you
could go to pure talk great supporter of
this show gives us the voicemail bag and
save a lot of money go to puretalk.com
select a plan enter promo code knowles
podcast save 50
off your first month i love puretalk i
use puretalk you should too switch over
in less than 10 minutes promo code
knowles podcast k-w-l-e-s
podcast all one word at puretalk.com
hey michael my name's steven i have a
little bit of a more serious question
for you so
my girlfriend and i have been together
for about two years uh we have a mutual
agreement that we're gonna wait to have
sex until marriage but there's a little
bit of a difference here
she
that she had like a religious awakening
right after college and vowed abstinence
after she graduated and i am actually a
virgin now while we've had this mutual
agreement of abstinence i had never
asked her how many guys she had slept
with but we got into a drunk
conversation last week
and she had told me that by the time she
had sworn abstinence before she had this
religious awakening she had slept with
hold on i wrote it down
she slept with 22 men six women and she
even told me she had two abortions one
which was very early and one which is
which was in a later stage
this kind of has me torn up because now
we both fear god and everything i i
guess my question to you is
if we get married uh do you think god
would still respect our marriage knowing
i mean her body count i guess you could
say
yeah this kind of has been torn up so i
appreciate your advice thank you so much
uh yes of course god would still respect
your marriage marriage is a sacrament
and it's
it's a real thing it's it's not
contingent on all sorts of other
questions around your emotions or on on
even the things that you've done in the
past i mean your your sins can be
forgiven
right you you have the opportunity to
repent
to uh go sin no more to have your sins
be forgiven by god because
christ dies on the cross for all of our
sins and redeems mankind i'm not sure if
you believe that but
uh i certainly believe that so
so yes uh if your question is will god
respect your marriage yes
if it's an illicit and legitimate
marriage and done in the right way then
yes
the the the act of marriage when two
people leave their families and come
together and become one flesh what god
has joined let no man separate that that
is a real action
no matter what your feelings happen to
be now
you might have some trouble with this
and you i would i would work through
that trouble and get past it before you
decide to get married if this if your
girlfriend's passed everybody's got a
pass but if your girlfriend's past is
just too much and you just can't you're
not going to be able to deal with that
well know that now don't take it out on
her later or leave her or hold it over
her head or anything like that
if if she is truly repented and she
thinks that's all awful and
especially the abortions that you know
she's
now firmly opposed to abortion and she's
working through the trauma of that and
you know she sought sought forgiveness
uh
if you if you can get past that then
certainly you know you can you can get
married and uh
if you can get past it god can get past
it okay i i uh so so long as the
repentance is sincere
uh but but it's a real thing i mean it's
also it's also not something to just
brush aside
that is a
that's a that's a traumatic way of
living
you know all those people to have been
intimate with and then and especially
the abortions it's a very traumatic
experience to go through so you gotta
you gotta also make sure your girlfriend
has worked through that uh as well uh
not not an easy
it it'll be a lot harder for you than it
will be for god but i don't overlook the
part of of you both working through that
yourselves but if you if you can work
through that repent and atone and move
on then
have a good marriage
i'm so glad that you liked that clip now
hold up before you go anywhere before
you go anywhere wait wait wait wait no
wait hold on wait
subscribe ring that bell get the
notifications get all of the new videos
that come out here we're closing in on a
million subscribers do it i want i want
to get there i want that i want that big
trophy i want to make sure that we can
spread truth before youtube completely
shuts us down so text email carrier
pigeon this youtube channel to your
friends we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you